il
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue sur des gones
à l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs avec une semaine très chargée
beaucoup d'actualité et se soit invitée
tout à fait particulier je reçois josé
de sousa champion du portugal junior en
1992 bonsoir josé une mosler c'est donc
chose et quand tu ma vie tu vas là la
faculté d'avoir la double nationalité
franco portugaise c'est ça exactement
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai pu jouer les
choper à une portugaise junior et puis
le gagner mais change
je suis né en france j'aurais aussi pu
participer aux championnats de france
ce que j'ai fait une fois aussi sur son
jeune voilà donc tu viens à paris en
fait donc et en 1992 tu fais le
championnat de france de donc portugal
junior et tu le remporte
voilà je crois à égalité avec deux
autres avec celles des autres
concurrents mais malheureusement alors
peut-être c'est l'occasion si donc vous
allez portugais nous explique de leur
passer un petit bonjour je tiens à
parler à la caméra
voilà donc je pense que le message est
passé à nos amis chasseurs qui des gens
derrière des portes une langue alors
portugais je crois c'est d'ailleurs
portugal-brésil foncia brésil 1 colony
aussi anciennement portugaise en chine
par macao ou alors en afrique aussi le
mozambique l'angola donc une langue
vraiment dissémine monde entier voilà
c'est ça voilà donc un éviter
internationale d'un des gones à l'eau
aujourd'hui alors je crois que tu
m'avais dit on va continuer sur ce
championnat du portugal
tu m'as donné une petite anecdote c'est
que tu avais pas joué cette année là tu
pouvais jouer en france aussi oui je
peux des enfants et tu n'as pas joué
parce que fait ce qu'ils avaient et
loire justement revanche qui d'habitude
présente l'émission chi l'ha n'a pas pu
être là donc voilà je les remplacer et
ont peu peur d'eux
oui machin mesure d'achever loi
finalement parce que depuis munich en
mai donc ces progrès qu'il avait utilisé
mon très fort et donc je suis allé au
portugal est bon j'ai bien fait puisque
j'ai gagné et je crois que cette
année-là il a gagné lui en france donc
c'est vrai donc tu as bien fait
peut-être j'ai bien fait débat alors
autre actualité aussi qui concerne
encore cette semaine c'est que la
semaine dernière on avait annoncé un
match contre judit polgar qui s'est
jouée sur le site go aww points gault
as.com et tu vas donc pu être dans les
cinq jours qui ont eu la chance dans la
rue contre visite au regard sectionné
oui ça c'était très difficile parce que
bon bon qu'en fait ce n'est même pas une
simultanée avons pensé que c'était une
simultanée au début finalement ça a été
un blitz et là ça a été très difficile
parce que le stress et tout est donc que
je me suis fait écraser jeu la salle
louis m'a fait un joli sacrifice de
tours pour me mater et ça a marché
voilà donc j'ai perdu j'étais un peu
tendu je crois que les cinq compères du
linge et jouer aussi et je ne suis pas
j'ai pas trop existe et c'était c'était
très difficile comme exercice parce que
je pense qu'elles doivent être aussi
soutenue par le public donc donc c'est
la première fois tu jouer contre la
meilleure joueuse du monde j'avais déjà
vu parce que j'ai vécu un peu à budapest
donc je l'avais vu là-bas déjà on
l'avait joué un match pourri karpov
c'était très impressionnant mais je semi
rapide mais sinon c'était la première
fois oui que je que je jouais contre
quelqu'un d'aussi fort aussi donc un bon
bon souvenir - très - trop tôt même que
le tournoi puisque classe internationale
à plus de 2200 points je crois oui c'est
ça oui à plus de 1000 et sont
pratiquement des 1300 donc oui c'est
déjà un très bon classement
international
voilà alors l'actualité cette semaine
c'est évidemment de francfort avec les
meilleurs joueurs du monde dont le giant
dénommé comme tel avec karpov
donc kasparov pour la première fois
ensemble depuis 96
karpov et kasparov kramnik et allande
meilleur joueur du monde voit la
meilleure du monde ce dernier s'est
terminée aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même je crois je enfin tout
ça m'a en fait d'après les dernières
nouvelles qu'on a je perds les détails
tout à fait mais donc ce soir c'était
donc des parties semi-rapides donc 20 25
minutes par joueur et les joueurs se
sont rencontrés plusieurs fois je crois
il son jeu ça peut jouer quatre fois
entre les eaunois oui chaque jour ils
jouaient les trois adversaires
voilà donc un dénouement finalement
assez intéressant puisque on résultat
final mais on ressent sur 20 sans
surprise encore une fois kasparov le
début de l'année dans le féminisme de
dire qu'il est très fort mais c'est
quand même incroyable parce que depuis
début d'année il écrase tout le temps
c'est à dire chat même les tournois
d'exhibition comme ça il n'est ce pas
une miette
il n'a pas joué pendant très longtemps
donc il a il a pu se préparer énormément
alors que les autres joueurs deviennent
honorer les invitations dans les
tournois lui s'est permis de faire une
pause de six mois je crois donc il a pu
se préparer énormément et on regarde et
les faiblesses de tel ou tel joueur à
telle ou telle ouverture est donc bon
c'est normal il récolte les fruits de
son travail je pense que
bon c'est un résultat mérité visons
vraiment beaucoup plus fort que les
autres alors excusé et beaucoup
d'énergie ou si on va y revenir juste a
pris puisque tu as une petite anecdote à
nous raconter deuxième kramnik vladimir
kramnik avec cinq points à un point et
demi du premier ce qui est quand même
considérable mais qui fait quand même
donc une bonne prestation
c'est derrière bernard de sauver un
petit peu les meubles avec 4 points et
demi je pense qu'à nantes justement
al'inverse lui il est riche je pense
qu'il est très fatigué par la saison qui
vient de jouer il a beaucoup joué
peut-être trop il n'est pas très bien
préparé son match aussi contre kasparov
qui doit un peu le mettre sur les nerfs
et donc il oblige et être de choisir des
ouvertures qui ne jouent pas d'habitude
pour ne pas dévoiler son répertoire et
c'est difficile contre les premières
jours du monde je pense et 4e père prof
oui là aussi en raison l'attendais aussi
peut-être
vous voyez disons que la verrez
peut-être un sursaut on va il est
maintenant faite s'immiscer vraiment je
pense à un joueur typique il s'entraîne
plus beaucoup il aime jouer
il joue à touba gammon on le voit jouer
jeu très tard aux cartes et tout mais
les échecs il n'a pas laissé tomber
d'elle disons l'entraînement je pense
quoi ils travaillent beaucoup moins
qu'avant et bon à ce niveau-là ça
pardonne pas et moins quand même il
arrive tiendra g haute aux autres
joueurs parce qu'il a ils ont un passé
exceptionnel donc alors on disait
kasparov vainqueur haut-la-main beaucoup
d'énergie pour kasparov certaines
anecdotes amusantes
ouais alors moi j'ai personnellement je
pense qu'à ce point fait un très bon
joueur pour trois raisons donc la
première la préparation il travaille
beaucoup plus qu'aux deux grands maîtres
là il a plu pendant six mois travaille
énormément
il a une énergie absolument
spectaculaire par exemple donc flir me
racontait qu il avait fait des tournois
jeunes parce qu'ils sont sensiblement du
même âge choisir on va peut-être
gameplay oui c'est avant d'offrir le
grand maître en iran m anglais qui
maintenant vie en france qui est marié
d'ailleurs avec christine flir une des
meilleures joueuses françaises et donc
et il a fait des championnats jeunes
avec lui et donc ces championnats jeunes
c'est toujours un peu la même chose on
partage des chambres en commun des
douches en commun etc
donc il a vu kasparov se laver les dents
et en se brossant les dents il arrachait
les poils de la brosse donc tellement il
dit que même le soir il a été pas le
matin ils arrachaient la brosse et les
blancs que c'était c'est des fantômes
j'aurais aimé voir ça mais
heureusement que je ne connaissais pas
et sinon le troisième point c'est que
justement donc la partie qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui va illustrer ce point là il
se prépare en fonction pour utiliser
cette énergie c'est à dire il va prendre
des parts il va se préparer en fonction
de cette énergie c'est à dire il va il
va choisir d ouverture qui lui
permettent d'exprimer cette énergie d
ouverture très tendu un petit peu voilà
pour lui de voir les rentrées dans
l'adversaire donc alors à côté de
francfort avant qu'on arrive évidemment
sur cette partie on va continuer à
décliner parce que à côté 20e tournoi b
entre guillemets ci que je n'avais donc
avec quatre joueurs qui jouaient donc
dans un théâtre devant je supposé
milliers de personnes j'ai pas les
détails mais ça m'étonnerait pas donc
dans le tournoi b entre guillemets donc
on retrouve de très grands joueurs alors
le premier et on a un classement final
jamais remis les joueurs de ce tournoi b
s'est amusé à la chine fait une machine
ces logiciels qui s'appelle frites donc
si darwin premier il y avait donc ils
ont accepté de faire jouer un logiciel
qui fait pas le point le plein des
points un très bon score
moi je trouve même impressionnant comme
si c'est vrai ou faux premier c'est du
semi rapides ou s'il adore les joueurs
mais quand on a peu de temps satin
minutes on aime le sujet évidemment nos
erreurs et l'ordinateur lui mais il est
implacable
mon erreur évidemment il ya disons
disons que je pense aussi que les grands
maîtres gagne parce qu'ils ont un côté
pratique c'est important c'est à dire
des fois ils vont pas jouer le meilleur
coup ils vont jouer un coup qui permet
d'attendre est bon les joueurs plus
faibles vont vont commencer à paniquer
et perdre l'ordinateur lui est pas du
tout donc il va toujours jouer et
essayer de jouer le meilleur coût et
puis quand j'ai l'image où est joué
c'est à dire là je dirais le version en
roue libre
un peu j'attends un petit peu voir ce
qui va se passer mon la l'ordinateur lui
rentrer dedans et il gagne quoi donc
ce qui est tragique alors on retrouve
quand même de très bons joueurs derrière
puisqu'on trouve en 2e une très belle
prestation aussi de peter les couples et
un écho dans l'écoulement droit qui fait
une très belle année semble-t-il
donc là il termine donc 2e 3e on
retrouvait ses lignes topaloff est aussi
a fait une bonne année il a fait une
partie superbe conte kasparov ont été
perdus bien aimée qui comme l'une des
parties une partie exceptionnelle qu'on
avait commenté didier bonnal d'ailleurs
je vous invite d'ailleurs à revoir nos
archives des missions cette partie
kasparov topalov qu'on a dû commenter
pour le mois de janvier ou février a été
commentée dans une émission de diagonale
c'est la partie de l'année pour
l'instant mais il faut dire aussi que
topaloff avait très mal joué l'année
précédente et donc là il s'est un peu
rattrapé des résultats un peu
catastrophique il avait eu avant que les
années précédentes donc topalov de
bulgares un oui en 4e on retrouve peter
vides l'un des tout meilleurs joueurs du
monde de ski russe lui est en 5e la
meilleure joueuse du monde me suis dit
que j'allais très bien je n'ai avoir
joué contre contre contre toi oui d'état
les états des massacres et non un peu
moins mais votre caf un très bon début
elle a réussi ses adversaires parce
qu'elle avait des positions un peu
défavorable elle a réussi à leur tendre
des pièges et à récupérer du matériel et
à gagner des parties importantes
elle s'accroche très bien oui d'accord
d'ailleurs demandant quand j'ai assisté
à ce match là contre karpov toutes les
parties même quand elle était moins bien
elle s'accrochait s'accrocher elle a
même fait tomber le champion du monde
qui lui a proposé une huile deux
secondes avant de tomber dans une
position peu supérieur et la dig en
continu et puis car peu fait tomber elle
avait gagné passer son temps voilà des
passants temps de réflexion est ce qu'on
appelle tombé à la gagner donc elle se
bat vraiment énormément
voilà elle alors 6e christopher loot
donc allemand et on retrouve septième
mais c'était la surprise de l'année là
il fait une petite corde contre
performance puisqu'il avait confirmé à
sarajevo où jolie tournant si alexander
morozevich il a après avoir perdu contre
judith s'est un peu écroulé semble-t-il
oui d'ailleurs et puis les 8e michael
adams qui est aussi des dix meilleurs
joueurs wii et qui sait c'est dommage de
revoir ainsi balle dans le dos un bon
choix de semi rapide je crois mais je
pense est vrai qu'il faut rappeler c'est
quand même un tournoi évidemment comme
plateau de rêve mais semi rapide selon
les parties entre guillemets officiels
qui sont de 2 heures par joueurs là
c'est plutôt 20 minutes par joueur donc
c'est plus pour spectacle et c'est très
intéressant je pense que c'est une forme
d'art qui va énormément se développer
donc je conseille à tous les gens qui
jouent aux échecs d'aller dans les coins
de semi rapide de jouer c'est de voir
les manières de progresser une finition
c'est à force de voir les spectacles
comme si on organisait sous ce format la
dernière une formation encore toutes
chaudes de cette semaine c'est la sortie
josé du classement international nouveau
classement international avec un record
absolu de places par an ce qui culmine à
1 2840 points elo bientôt 2000 c'était
quoi pascal ans trois restent scotchés à
2007 170,2 court numéro 2 qui a scotché
entre guillemets mais ouais mais quand
on veut kasparov on se demande où sait
où il va aller
c'est incroyable de 1841 points elo
c'est là qu'en fait il n'a pas
d'opposants en fait oui c'est ça je
pense l'information la principale parce
que je pense il ya quand même une
inflation extraordinaire du vélo est
donc bon 2840 points
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je sais pas
trop mais ce que je sais c'est qu'il est
beaucoup plus fort que les autres et ça
c'est la différence qui compte voilà
référence à 10 sur encore pas vraiment
le niveau parce que bon de 1946 on va
dix ou vingt ans en arrière
bon
il n'aura peut-être pas ce classement là
avec la force qu'il a aujourd'hui opté
sans classe manquez pas tout à fait à
jour puisque mon avis tu passes à la 4e
place mondiale passant devant shirov
mais il semblerait que le tournoi de
sarajevo n'est pas encore été
comptabilisées donc peut-être des
petites modifications
donc on en reparlera sûrement d'un
terminal ce nouveau classement
international
la semaine prochaine je suis je si
l'information que quelques lautier oui
là pour les français si vous l'essayez
au premier plan 1000 m voilà joël
lautier notre fameux numéro 1 mondial
qui était qui était tombé en dessous de
griffiths en points se retrouve à 2638
points et récupère la 39e place mondiale
dont qu'il reprendrait ce vers le sommet
et son objectif s'est dit semaine
prochaine de rentrer dans les dix
meilleurs du monde et on pense tous en
france qui va y arriver et donc avec
etienne bacrot et bien justement etienne
bacrot aussi qui dans le nouveau nouveau
classement semi rapide puisque
maintenant la fidh tient compte du semi
rapide
c'est une forme de classement un nouveau
classement mondial à semi rapides et là
on voit bacrot dans les 20 premiers
joueurs mondiaux à plus de 2600 points
donc c'est assez exceptionnel quand même
il faut je pense qu'il faut le souligner
kasparov différents partis encore voilà
comme il n'a pas joué pendant très
longtemps ils content de toi francfort
si les contrôles a éclaté donc à suivre
ce nouveau classement est ce qu'on va
perdurer on va voir en tout cas ce que
ça peut donner dans les derniers mois
qui viennent ce nouveau classement semi
rapide mais je pense que les joueurs ont
tout haut ce basée sur le classement
ouais mais bon ça de bon
nous pour commenter on se basera sur ce
placement d'office qu'on verra si
d'acord et je respecte cette hiérarchie
voilà je crois qu'on va passer à notre
parti compter du jour où josé puisque
c'est la partie donc de france foi en la
partie de kasparov contre hanovre le
numéro deux mondial
c'est intéressant à plus d'un titre
d'abord parce que la partie est
intéressante mais aussi parce que kaspar
anciens doit se retrouver pour un match
de championnat du monde en tout cas
désigné comme tel au mois d'octobre donc
match qui est hors les instances de la
fille traditionnel de la fédération
internationale des échecs la fidh et
donc ces deux joueurs se rencontrent à
ce moment là
qu'est ce qui va se passer on peut
supposer que c'est le choc des titans en
tout cas alors bien que je dois marquer
c'est la partie à mon avis ne reflète
pas n'est pas à l'image du match qui va
avoir lieu
je pense que le nom n'a pas voulu jouer
disons son répertoire habituel il est
tombé dans la préparation de kasparov
il a joué dans le sens de kasparov
justement donc je disais que kasparov
c'était la préparation l'énergie et se
prépare justement fonctions dans
fonction de cette qualité là et elle est
à londres est tombé en plein dedans
donc je pense pas qu'ils
je pense pas qu'il jouera même des
quatre prochains matchs ou alors des
positions qui favorise annoncé qu'ils
favorisent cas sport en tout cas à mon
fère le niveau jeu lé conseil où
j'allais des conseils de ne pas jouer ce
genre d'ouverture qui favorise
énormément caspar en fait pas du tout
annoncé plus tôt un stratège
d'accord mais on va voir or c'est de
partir maintenant l'occasion d'en
reparler
ah pardon mais voilà la vidéo à
disposition sur notre écran je vous
rappelle que si vous nous rejoignez ce
soir pour la première fois que vous
pouvez suivre aussi cette partie avec
nous en cliquant donc sur la
présentation de diagonale sur le petit
bouton jouer qui vous fait accéder sur
un applet sur un applet java sur lequel
vous pouvez suivre la partie avec nous
vous avez aussi la possibilité si vous
avez un logiciel qui permet de lire les
parties pgn que nous vous offrons si
deux exemples 1 pour pc et pour mac dans
la partie émission si vous cliquez sur
émission vous pourrez télécharger ses
logiciels
vous pouvez aussi donc suivre cette
partie en téléchargeant le fichier pgn
qui est le format standard sur internet
de pour stocker les parties d'échecs
voilà donc deux solutions pour vous
l'applet java ou un logiciel spécifique
pour télécharger le fichier pgn associés
comme nous vous offrons aussi
voilà donc josé de challandes contre
kasparov en fait voilà puisse
correspondre off aller noir voilà voilà
alors optez de voir déjà tout de suite
aimé les premiers coups donc d4 ce que
je joue pas d'habitude normalement et
non d'un temps de jeu plutôt qu'à tous
cavaliers f3 ces derniers temps mais bon
il transpose plutôt sur des 4 mai
l'accord d'un connaissance c'est plus
simple et plus et moins dans son
habitude
voilà c'est moins de 5,8 donc alors donc
ce que fait kasparov alors hissé le son
coup favori 5 km et 6 et puis s'il peut
il a transposé
destin viennent dans ces grandes fait
lille préfère disons d ouverture qui
laisse les blancs venir au centre pour
ensuite miné le centre avec le fou sur
la grande diagonale
alors voyons les prochains coups donc
classique le coup ces deux c4 qui permet
de contrôler aussi le centre d'un coût
normal de développement on peut pas
jouer le pion du roi puisque le cavalier
fils évidemment les cavaliers sortie
contrôler cette case pour l'instant pas
alors j'ai justement cavaliers psy c'est
la même fonction que des 5 c'est à dire
empêcher 1,4 alors des cinq ans rappelle
c'est le coup de la dame ici si les
noirs v12 cousine cours ont lieu au lieu
où oui au premier coup même au lieu de
cabaye m6 le but était d'empêcher e4
comme comme ce coup de la fatigue ou de
cavaliers voilà donc voila un petit peu
les idées qu'on a déjà développé
plusieurs fois dans cette émission
puisqu'on a déjà vu cette ouverture les
noirs donc joue le petit coup ici à
droite qui va rentrer fiant kétou ce
qu'on appelle un point très tôt le fou
va venir ici se fout ici le rite et
suite va venir sur la case angers7
pour contrôler ici une grande diagonale
noir et faire pression sur ce sens et
faire pression sur le central la voiture
qu'on appelle moderne on laisse les
blancs venir et après avec allons les
suivre à envahir le sens là un mieux le
contre-attaqué pas exactement pour le
contre-attaqué même cas donc la langue
choisie un coup logique encore une fois
de développement ce coût de
développement de caries c3 al'avantage
de contrôler maintenant les cases
blanches au centre éco nature et avoir
la possibilité pour les blancs
maintenant de pousser ses pions
accélérions comme tu préciser c'est le
but de d'envahir d'envahir le centre
toujours des coups classiques alors la
première déjà premier embranchement
kasparov a l'habitude de jouer soit
cette défense avec ce coup donc on est
au numéro 3 des noirs le coup de 17 en
dessin qui contre attaque au centre
direct justement empêchant tout chaud là
on là il décide d'empêcher un peu 4 ou
alors d'agir tout de suite sur le sens
donc empêcher ce coup de pions ici eu
deux ans le 4 avec ce pion en d5
l'autre possibilité pour kasparov était
de jouer le fou la fuite sur la case g7
permettant aux blancs d'envahir le
central le 4 mai
ensuite le contre attaquant est ce qui
s'appelle la défiance est indienne
estonienne donc là il choisit une autre
embranchements qui s'appelle cette fois
la défensive
grunfeld voilà encore un nom qui est
intéressant de connaître aux échecs
c'est intéressant de connaître les noms
des merveilleux je pense parce que bon
souvent elles sont référencés comme ça
dans les livres dont quand on connaît
pour cherche directement et c'est une
ouverture qui était pratiqué par cas
sport depuis très longtemps donc il a
une très grosse expérience alors
qu'attendent la joue avec les noirs mais
pas avec les blancs ou moins souvent et
blanc donc déjà bon café le même feeling
voilà déjà à mon cas sport fait bien
préparé il connaît très bien ouverture
grosse expérience et en plus comme je
disais ah non c'est un stratège ses
dires il aime bien replacé les pièces
par exemple s'il a un fou mal placée en
f3 il va je fous d un four b3 pour bien
leur place et il aime bien les positions
semi-ouverte disons où il ya un peu de
contacts de pions qui permettent de
faire des mains de faire des manoeuvres
il est très fort dans les manoeuvres on
peut regarder beaucoup de parties de lui
vous verrez et du parti c'est souvent
par des très jolies manoeuvres de
cavaliers de food diagne moins punchy
voilà ils cassent parents et la kasparov
donc va tout de suite contre attaqué le
centre et ça va le mettre en difficulté
à nantes alors voyons la suite donc à
nantes joue voilà le coup donc cavalier
f3 suivi par la réponse logique du
kasparov le fou âgé de 7 ans 8 voilà un
coup alors un coup voilà qui pose la
question noire secoue dame b 3 ici
exerce avec ce pion à ses quatre une
pression supplémentaire sur le pion des
noirs crettenand à choisir est-ce que je
prend on pas l'avantagé ou
l'inconvénient c'est que s'ils ne
reprenne évidemment sur le côté ça
permet aux blues d'envahir le centre
maintenant les autres pions va être
serré
par contre l' avantage pour les noirs
c'est que ça peut gagner un temps pour
mobiliser leur foi l'appui pour surtout
parce que mon avantage de ce coup c'est
qu'elle permet permet d'agir sur le
centre mais la dame aussi est très
exposée ont souvent on dit aux débutants
ne peuvent surtout pas jouer la dame dès
le début sans l'assortir radicale et
elle peut se faire tacler comme elle
vaut cher dès qu'une pièce attaques de
faible valeur il faut soit reculée donc
soit dégradé un peu sa position donc
c'est ça peut être faire attention avec
la dame faire attention à ne pas la
sortir tout de suite dès le début et
j'insiste sur un point pour les gens qui
débutent un peu c'est le centre toujours
faire attention au centre et là vous
avez bien regardé kasparov et à nantes
vont toujours jouer au centre et c'est
le centre qui toujours chi chi chi le
principal qui disent on est le thème de
voix la verte et l'ouverture et puis le
thème des échecs il faut toujours faire
attention semble parce que au centre les
pièces sont le maximum de rayonnement
quand vous mettez un cavalier au säntis
contre lui case
quand vous mettez sur la bande il en
contrôle 4 donc voilà c'est quoi ton
dans le coin alors là il est
complètement excentré deux cases donc
toujours les pièces au centre c'est là
qu'elle rayonne de plus et c'est pour ça
que les grands joueurs jouent toujours
au centre et la voyez tous les coups
sont dirigés vers le centre donc las
vegas par au final donc choisi de
prendre dans ces cas c'est un choix il
repousse et de consolider son centre
aussi avec voilà on le sait c'est en c6
par les bons là il avait une stratégie
passive et comme liste des joueurs
actifs est bon il préfère laisser les
blancs je me sente et miner ce centre
c'est le contre attaquer voilà comment
attaquer fortement donc la non
évidemment logiquement reprend avec la
dame l'avantagent maintenant pour les
blancs c'est que ce pion maintenant
devant le roi pouvoir envahir le centre
ville libre et donc les plus contrôlées
par ce cavalier il ya plus le plan nord
qui a empêché jean piché ce mouvement
mais en échange bon la dame est exposée
peut-être ça le plus embêtant voilà en
fait c'est le
c'est la contrepartie disons
contrepartie
alors la casse par ont choisi de faire
un coup de très logique petit rhum et
après peut dire option maths à l'abri
exactement va pouvoir engager des
actions exactement alors que le rock le
rock danon puis alors que roy blanc est
encore aux 110 en consentant
il va perdre donc s'ils jouaient de 4,1
temps il développe le fou de temps alors
de 4 nages aux ide on le rappelle que
c'est le coup ici au centre le pion
devant le roi va pouvoir jouer le fou
pas pouvoir sortir et après vite
mettront à la banque parce que les noirs
vont pouvoir exploser rapidement le
centre vont sacrifier les matériels pour
exploiter la position pour exploiter la
position du roi blanc disons que le
thème le plus classique c'est lorsque le
roi est au centre est mal protégé
on essaye d'ouvrir les lignes est
souvent le meilleur moyen de welling
c'est le sacrifice du matériel un pion
une pièce pour ouvrir droit à le mettre
sous le feu de ses propres pièces mais
je vous rassure un an de koné cette
position il sait où il va donc pour
l'instant on n'est pas inquiet pour lui
voilà on n'est pas inquiet pour les deux
joueurs
donc là il joue le coup logique e24 là
maintenant les blanc domine parfaitement
le centre depuis son superbe ici qui
n'ont pas de pause en noir dont qui
contrôle contrôle assez bien ces deux
classes par les cavaliers qui protège
les cases et ses documents contrôler
eux-mêmes ces quatre cars ici devant
donc une position centrale pour les
stands juillet en faveur des blancs les
bannettes oui les blancs contrôler tout
le centre c'est à dire 4 donc donc
quatre vingt cinq des quatre des 4 et
des 5 c'est-à-dire et contrôler tout le
centre mais bon donc c'est pour ça que
la grande fête de szczecin ouverture
très dangereuse est bon je recommande
pas à tout le monde de la jouer après
d'avoir vu faire très très attention
sert il faut ils font là celui blain se
regroupent voilà il vient consolider
notre la bombe à 30h se fait écraser
très vite et donc c'est pour ça que les
joueurs qui jouent la graine fel sont
souvent des joueurs qui sont très bien
préparés ou qui sont assez jeunes qui
aiment les ouvertures parce que il faut
toujours être à la pointe de son il faut
tout de suite pas laissé le temps de
consolider cette avance voilà toutes les
nouveautés sont importantes donc les
joueurs plutôt qu'ils m'ont qui étudient
- je leur déconseille rèset cette
variante qu'il faut bien maîtriser pour
jouer d'accord oui c'est quand même
impressionnant les pions les quêtes et
des quatre pouces et s'avance et ses
deux pions par exemple ce pour attaquer
le cavaliere si le cavalier noir sortait
sur cette case mais ce pion pour pousser
aussi beaucoup de possibilités pour les
blancs alors que les noirs justement ils
ont du mal à sortir leurs pièces un peu
n'importe où il faut qu'il fasse très
attention donc la casse par jouer un
coup curieux en tout cas qu'on peut
juger comme tel c'est évidemment connu
ici c'est un curieux c'est un coût qui
sort le cavalier à la bande donc tu 18 à
l'heure moins actifs qu'au sens moins
actif donc donc d'où une ouverture très
bonne chose parce que bon si on ne
connaît pas cette ouverture là on va pas
jouer cavalier si cette manière
naturelle
mais ce cavalier si c'est un très bon
coup puisqu'il il permet ces 5
c'est cette c5 alors il permet le coup
ce cavalier à six qui contrôle une case
proche du centre là exactement peut
permettre à ce point noir de jouer en
ses 7 ans et 7 6 5
avec un contrôle social à on peut noter
aussi que c'est que ce qu ali avait
tenté de sortir vers le centre il aurait
été justement comme l'a dit c'est
repoussé par les pions blancs avec des
gains de temps et d'espacé pour les
blancs traitement donc malheureusement
on est obligés de d'excentrer un peu le
cavalier pour pouvoir agir au centre
c'est alors que c'est assez curieux et
donc c'est pas très naturel c'est pour
ça que c'est une ouverture qu'il faut
bien connaître avant de jouer on peut
noter peut-être chose et que
une autre possibilité aurait été de
mettre ce cavalier sur cette case avec
toujours la possibilité de contrôler la
casse et 5
oui mais le désavantage peut-être de
boucher voilà de l'inde vers grenade et
se fout là est très important dans la
grande fête de 6 parce que si on regarde
bien la couleur sur laquelle est la dame
positionne adam voilà vous quasi blanche
et le fouet et finalement et blanc donc
et les caisses de retraite même son b3
qui une case blanche donc le fou le
foufou padam padam a énormément donc si
on joue cavalier b17 en bouche ce fou et
donc on limite les possibles d'actions
sur la dame
et comme la contrepartie de cette
position c'est la dame la mauvaise la
faiblesse de la position de la dame
blanche
bon il faut surtout pas enfermer ce fou
qui est très puissant et très important
une pièce très importante mais
maintenant cette ouverture
voilà donc que faire en attendant ben
joue un coup logique maintenant il sort
ce fou pour faire le petit rock voilà ça
continue donc les stratégies à part la
belgique ont fait absolument que le roi
se mettent à l'abri et que cette tour
éventuellement viennent au centre
puisqu'avec ses pions en vain c'est une
tour derrière serait assez puissante
et puis on soutenu par la tour pourrait
créer des menaces très dangereux dans le
camp noir à la casse par joue le coup le
fameux procès cinq mois j'ai envie de
dire attention parce que les blancs
pourrait prendre le pion voilà on ne
voit pas ce qui empêche les blancs alors
alors avec le pion il faudrait prendre
avec le pion des cadres puisque
évidemment le cavalier protégés de casse
donc la dame si la dame prenait
évidemment la sagem seraient perdus ou
alors il faut prendre avec le pion s'ils
prennent avec le pion maintenant on peut
sortir
alors on a dévié le pion du centre c'est
à l'option était était en d4 il
contrôlait 25 et il pouvait être poussé
sur des cinq et on l'a dévié puisqu'il a
pris prend ses cinq et on peut donc
sortir le fou maintenant on est six
salles au crâne
alors voila voila livier c'est
qu'effectivement si les blancs prenez ce
pion le fou si vite ici pourrait sortir
par exemple en est par exemple avec
action sur la dame blanche et la dame là
je suis un petit peu embêté voilà n'a
plus la possibilité de pousser le client
pourra là pour boucher le fou puisque ce
pion et il n'y a pas vraiment eu à se
caser pour la fois pour pour la dame est
bon s'il avait parlé bon il n'y a pas
vraiment de bonnes cases et en plus la
tour à 8 va venir en jeu tu as envie de
venir en jeu et là c'est torrent s'est
mis la pression sur les banques et on a
vu et on regarde encore que le juana par
ok donc les noirs sacrifie 1
un petit pion pour beaucoup d'activités
d'activité une bonne avance
développement et si ils le récupèrent
ils ont une partie très confortable même
gagné donc au vu de cette analyse que
fait annan bernanke choisi de pousser
leurs adhérents coup tout à fait logique
et un coût qui empêche le couffo aussi
voilà exactement et qui garde le
contrôle du centre par contre les noirs
en échange on a vu que les noirs avaient
pas lutter pour le centre sa guérison
obtenue quelque chose puisqu'ils
contrôlent maintenant avec ce plan c'est
simple la fameuse une des fins voiles à
la casse dès qu une des fameuses quatre
centrales notamment la casse des quatre
saisons qui peut devenir éventuellement
un point fort pour les noirs voilà en
tout cas ils ont ils ont déjà à
contre-attaqué en ayant plus ils ont
ouvert la diagonale du fou g7
voilà c'est alors que l'on mène à une
fois que ce pion à jouer maintenant on
peut imaginer que ce cavalier bouge et
du coup le fou g7 a vu ça devrait
s'ouvrir avec des possibilités d'action
maintenant très très longue
qu'est-ce qui est maintenant placé sur
des gones à qui est très longtemps c'est
une pièce une pièce maîtresse de la
bonne feuille alors là kasparov joue le
coup encore un coup on appelle ça un
coup pour miner voilà un cookie min et
un coup logique puisque vous voyez nos
droits ou dans la le roi n'a pas encore
le roi n'a pas encore qui est le roi est
encore de 1 donc je joue aussi j'essaie
d'ouvrir la colonne de pour mettre une
tour en 1 8
voilà c'est à dire que les leaders
kasparov avait joué le coup de 7 6 c'est
par exemple de jouer lyon prend l'après
pions prend et blanc latour et suite ici
viennent sur la case de 8 avec une très
belle colonie nerfs et pourrait mettre
en difficulté en difficulté le
somaliland lioret plus de pions ni de
son corps ni de l'autre quand donc on a
plus âme qui ont ouvert voilà il
permettrait d'avoir une action très
longue dans le calme alors moi je ferai
une petite précision sur les colonnes
ouverte la colonne verte n'est pas
toujours la colonne où il n'ya pas de
pions c'est à dire ça peut être aussi
une colonne si vous avez une tour noire
et si vous n'avez pas de pions noirs sur
cette colonne à mon sens c'est une
colonne ouverte aussi aux semi ouverte
oui je fais appeler ça ouverte parce que
on l'a directement une action sur le
camp adverse par exemple puis henri iv
peut-être un peu attaquées ou même un
pion aux trois peut pas jouer trois moi
j'appelle ça une colonne ouverte mais on
mais c'est vrai que
toutes ses envies du tout c'était alors
voyons ce que fait maintenant annonce
choisi donnons pas de paris agir au
centre évidemment s'il avait pris du
plomb le sort de l'expansion gagner avec
un gain de temps d'arrêter un très
mauvais coup de prendre ce serait
laisser le centre au blanc au noir
pardon on doit donc avec vos petits rock
qui laisse les noirs choisir de prendre
ici on prend mais il peut reprendre
union alors ne pas se dévoiler
maintenant donc le coup suivant va
amener la deuxième idée des noirs et
noir prennent
voilà qui est d'isoler le pion le pion
des 5 parce que après la reprise d'un an
beaucoup numéro 11
il reprend un petit échange au centre on
peut noter effectivement que ce pion des
cinq des blancs on appelle ça
effectivement désole quand tu lalani
zolani on appelle ça j'aime bien les
terres donc est alors eni vous invite
chossy disait une idée très importante
il disait que s'il ce pion alors ceux
qui ont donné une force une force aux
pièces blanches donc dans le cas de
figure parce que voyez les blancs en
plus des espaces et contrôler plus de
cases et donc ça permet un développement
plus facile mais en même temps non plus
par an + ce pion peut avancer plus les
forces les blancs on développe un
potentiel agressif cependant voilà ils
sont plus d'espacé donc ça avance et on
se prend ce pion menace d'aller à dame
voilà plus en plus le bon de la tête et
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote loti a battu
allende en poussant ses pions jusqu'à
dame
il a joué des six des sept épis damehane
honda a perdu contre lautier n'avait pas
il a pas réussi à empêcher la baisse du
pew voilà dans une défense dans la
défendre une file donc maintenant on
avait tout faux les noirs gwenn on avait
les noirs donc c'est une partie
intéressante donc là alors c'est à la
fois une force alors si tu faiblesse si
la case devant le pion et contrôle et
sert si on ne peut pas justement avancer
ce pion voilà parce que ce pion il faut
noter
désavantage physique ce qui n'est pas il
peut pas obtenir une protection de notre
pions voilà exactement pour le protéger
faut une pièce voilà et donc ça y est ça
y est dit dans une pièce à la défense
finalement voilà c'est un petit peu et
est donc dit mme david je disais aussi
que donc si le pion la casque et qui
devant le pion est faible le pion est
faible donc il faut mettre un cavalier
devant ce pion parce que le cavalier
comme le pion est isolé ne peut pas être
chassé il n'y a pas de pions sur les sur
les colonne latérale et donc il ne
pourra jamais être chassé donc si
maintenant on transpose un cavalier en
d6 et bien donc si les noirs arrivé à
mettre en cavale et par exemple le kuga
value8 la précarité des six voies label
et l'ocré interne en la position serait
extraordinaire action alors voyons ce
qui se passe pour les noirs maintenant
donc casper choisi de continuer son
développement
il sort tout simplement son fou à la
souffrance est vite permettait à la tour
c 8 éventuellement devenir en jeu voilà
exactement il sort ses pièces
tranquillement ils contrôlent encore une
case centrale et contrôler la case de
quatre mois ça il est normal qu'un
contrôle de cas centrale la case des
quatre avec le pion 600 et la case de 4
avec le cavalier et le plus fou donc ça
y est les noirs ont réagi au centre
voilà ils ont quand même un petit
contrôle du blanc un pion quand même qui
peut s'avérer dangereux ça va être
dangereux faible et c'est dallas est là
et c'est là que l'agilité et c'est là
est ce que c'est une force une faiblesse
c'est la discussion qui va s'opérer donc
là maintenant mais à nantes protège son
point fort c'est une règle si vous
essayez toujours de vue d'ailleurs sur
toi t'es sur que je conseille à tout le
monde de dire mon système fait un peu
ardu mais il évoque beaucoup d'idées
l'idée de la surprotection c'est que
maintenant la tour bon évidemment plus
permis au secteur de pousser la poussée
de la tour c'est que quand il ya trois
pièces qui protège le pion sur plus de
de défense voilà chacune de ces pièces
maintenant libre de bouger libre de
bouche et puis s'il avance de votre
continue s'ils avancent il avance ses
pions il va libérer tout ce potentiel
alors voilà on va voir donc comment ça
se passe donc là maintenant kasparov
sort lui-même sadaf défis communs en
avait sorti sa dame vient b3 et b4
lui-même il la sort sur la case b6 et
même temps il permet éventuellement une
tour et de guérir jour sur la classe des
8 par exemple à tours à huit devenir un
jeu donc ajouta une pièce d'un jeu et
faisant pression lui-même sur le soutien
de son soutien des 5 alors c'est là que
je que c'est là qu'à nantes joue le coup
alors oui alors juste avant de voir le
coût danone ne sais pas encore je mets
mon poème revenir un petit peu en
arrière si tu permets ici dans cette
position kasparov est déjà jouée cette
position au moins trois fois mes
connaissances dont deux fois contre
karpov
il ya déjà douze ans donc il la connaît
très très bien donc je pensais déjà une
petite erreur de la part d'anne en ayant
plus on voit que c'est une ouverture qui
libèrent beaucoup d'énergie donc moi
hélas ici à ici qu'à sport mais jouer
tour f 8 8
il avait donc ouvert la colonne e
d'akwaya j'ai jamais le coutour en 8 ou
la tour en 1 8 contre kharkov il avait
joué sa carte offre maintenant avait
poussé le pion en d6 voilà oui hélas
kasparov avait joué le petit coup h6 de
côté alors petit coup voilà ici
du coup de pioche à avoir ici sur cette
case et maintenant donc c'est juste pour
exprimer l'idée ça va être un petit peu
ça fait deux trois courants encore un
coup ils cassent picard préfet joseph au
f4 le fou ici était venu sur laquelle s
4 et maintenant kasparov avait joué le
cavaly en dix-sept justement pour
bloquer voilà pour bloquer le pion donc
là on exprimait l'idée il libère le fou
g7 et bloque le pion il a gagné cette
partie il a fait nul deux nuls deux fois
la même position de fois nul et après il
avait gagné contre un en simultanée
contre un jeune il avait battu toujours
avec tours 8 mais tour d'amd si c'est un
coup de vivre dimanche contre bari of a
party mariés vivent de choc
connaissant ce oui mais selon certaines
positions donc alors voyons donc
en 98 des jeux 14 ans
dans ce cas la béninoise un petit peu
alors donc l'export foule a suivi la
théorie est à mon avis ah non deux
connaît aussi très bien cette partie
mais quel sport fait mieux préparés on
va on va le voir on va le voir
alors donc est donc maintenant à nantes
joue le coup qui paraît logique de thons
libérés ces forces du cou à des 50 des
six alors posé la question en velours
noir attention ce plus on peut devenir
très dense temps et on peut pas trop
aller jusqu'en début puisque ses
protégés beaucoup mais déjà il ya des
cases dans le père noir qui sont des
films nationaux et menaçant s'est jamais
d'aller à dame peut menacer dallas a en
tout cas kasparov ne va pas bloquer un
des fils donc on avance c'est tout à
fait naturel
et d'ailleurs si la dame avait était
resté en des andes et huit par exemple
donc à nantes aurait pu jouer ou g5 les
menaçant le cavalier déjà de sauter en
d5 pas déjà ce qui se passera sait déjà
mais c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça
qu'il a joué et qu'il est là qu'il a
joué des fils pour gagner des cases
parce que là il gagne la casse des cinq
caisses à nantes a gagné laquelle cinq
pour placer un cavalier par exemple ce
cavalier pour la sûreté sur la case
d'enseignement là c'est pas un bon coup
mais mes selles sont annotées voila
voila c'est possible donc c'est pour ça
que plus on avance ses pions plus ça
libère de la force alors voyons ce que
fait maintenant casse parfait même
logique angélique voie d'un
développement la tour en a huit qui
jouait pas tellement là bien sûr la
casse des vite et puis qui bloque le
pion qui fait une pression sur ceux plus
un bloc l'option puisque maintenant on
peut pas pousser jusqu'au 18 et puis ça
l' attaque aussi ça commence à l'attaqué
ça commence à une pression même les
noirs menace de prendre le client vous
voyez il a une classe de fer peut
reprendre pions et ben justement envoyé
une réunion tout simplement il le pion
la casse devant le pion est faible il
est bien arrêtée maintenant on peut
l'attaquer sans peur et puis donc
mettons un petit peu en difficulté les
blancs sur quoi on en est un je vous le
coup voilà alors le coup que tu me dises
est la moins chère peu voilà le coup
qu'avaya 4 alors moi je n'aime pas
beaucoup parce que là ils attaquent la
dallas par en fin d'étape d'amica sport
mais ce cavalier était au centre contre
les dessins qui contrôlait le 4 et on va
et contrôler beaucoup de cases on met
sur la bande
c'est un peu curieux c'est à dire pour
moi mon ex entre les pièces
volontairement mais c'est vrai que matt
hagan pression des six il faut agir mais
moi je préférais le ku'damm b 5 au lieu
de cavaliers de carbone et donc s'il
revient à son arrière voilà d'un b5
ici tu penses à donc au 14e coup des
blancs qui propose plutôt le coût d'un
dessin notre dame et saint bris plus plu
à la raison pourquoi parce que la dame
est un peu un peu un peu un peu faible
en c4 donc on joue d'hommes b5 s'y prend
on ne pouvait pas voir ils peuvent le
people mais non se venge sur b cet abri
d'accord cercle
les blancs dans ce cas-là prendrait la
tour imaginons dame b5 et noir prendre
prendre la tour les pions gamme détour
des huîtres en pions des six exactement
les blancs joué le coup tout reprend des
six tours prend des six il ya près le
coût des noirs dan prendre des six la
dame se venge sur le pion bessette et
intérêts car le cavalier le pion à cet
attaquant lecavalier avec la dame et le
fou cela il faut pas oublier un
exactement et la dame intégrer aussi la
dame le pion à 7 ce serait donc mauvais
points noirs et en plus maintenant avec
les dames en bessin qu on libère le la
pression sur b2 ah oui c'est à dire que
la dame partagerez la casse b2 a le foot
blanc du coude pour sortir en plus et
maintenant si les blancs c'est noir
récupèrent en b 5
le cavalier vient s'installer en b5 et
contrôler le plan des six donc madame b
5 ça me semble un coup intéressant
ils ont plus dans la logique des échecs
comme il ya 4 mai maintenant bon c'est
super grand est donc à tendance existe
un petit peu consacré un petit peu mais
tout ça on reste sceptique
le cavalier en d'accord on a quatre mois
pour voir comment je suis très sceptique
et d'ailleurs quel score va le prouver
ce que mon avis et c'est un mauvais coup
mais bon on verra ça dans la suite
peut-être canon de cavalia 4 va vous
faire une nouvelle interview jours pour
dire que l'on va coûter des bêtises et
qu'un km à castets un bon coup les
intervenants oui on veut dire oui donc
on a reçu il ya deux semaines raid
intégral qui tu as écouté cet été à un
moment intéressant c'est vrai alors vous
qui reviennent pour me dire qu'il aurait
fallu jouer d'accord donc la casse par
jouer un coup logique la dame est
attaquée tout simplement il la replace
sur la casse et 6 elle est bien passé
cette dame
finalement alors qu'à la mentionnons que
la fameuse partie qu'on mentionne que
qu'on avait nettoyé par les barrières
vivant de choc a vu le coût d'un b 4-0
le jouet dame c6 est vendu choc avait
joué dame b4y avait joué le même coup
comme il ya quatre ans voila voila il
avait même coup mais c'est c'était une
partie où barrière a perdu la qualité
mais il a obtenu beaucoup de
compensation et donc
c'était un séminaire une partie du nom
avant le choc avait gagné ils vendent
tout cas va gagner mais donc les noirs
avaient quand même gagné déjà cette
partie donc c'est déjà un signal mais je
pense que si kasparov nabajoth dmb 4
c'est qu'ils savaient qu'ils avaient
quelque chose et si la nand a accepté de
rentrer de vente là c'est que lui aussi
avait trouvé quelque chose mais quand
même si c'est beaucoup plus fort donc le
ku'damm se situe oui d'avoir contrôle
des quatre centrales toutes les
centrales exercent toujours une pression
sur des 6es sur le cavalier sur les sur
lesquels média qu'est la dame peut pas
par exemple avis sur la case d3 par
exemple imaginons le cari serait perdu
voilà une petite pression sur ce
qu'elles valent une puissance ou kayak à
une pression sur des six on peut noter
que si par exemple les blancs et c'est
de protéger ce cavalier
oui ça a réveillé le fou puisque la tour
ici soit sans défense pour lecavalier
pourrait jouer avec une prime m
et même on prendrait le pion des six
aussi au pire et on pourrait tout
prendre mission donc c'est beau c'est
que là bas il va jouer il va jouer un
coup donc là un an de jouer un coup qui
paraît aussi logique floue 3 qui
instaure une pression sur le pion c5
alors il se doit on ce soit l'idée
peut-être là si c'est l'idée de ding
dang c'est qu'il est un ska valley prend
voilà en fait il va il va se manger y
donne des 6 mai se venge sur ces 5
voilà vous propose un échange document
légal et propose et et au final ça
serait peut-être une position que chacun
sache est minorée vers la nulle je
n'aurais pas dû six en option comme
armand symétrique au final voilà oui en
fait je n'ai pas su pas bien plus donc
en tout cas la casse port va faire va
faire un coup très fort là il joue au
16e au 15e coup 13e coup des noirs
casques à renflouer un coup c'est la
preuve regardez regardez la différence
entre entre le cavalier à quatre
cavaliers quatre cavaliers ou 4 un coup
centrale contre un coup comme acer que
le canada joue à cavalier ces trois à
quatre qui défend des 4 et puis
maintenant et j'espère en tout cas média
6 e 4 donc il prend la case il ya pas
photo entre les deux ils se servent à la
cavale et c est maintenant là on se
regarde bien il contrôle le saint qui
contrôlent des quatre cantons il a
menacé nord c'est de prendre des six
semaines amplement de 6 et de défendre
ses 5 et le cavalier protège la casse et
c'est donc là je pense que déjà assez
amusant mais cela a noté
déposer un petit motif géométrique c'est
que le cavalier à six contrôles c5 qui
lui même contrôlé par le carillon et ses
deux cavaliers sont un petit peu en fait
maintenant vraiment relâché on va mettre
le cavalier blanc de 6 pour faire un
sujet avait trimé c'est pas possible il
faudrait que le cavalier grâce à 75
morts chacun protège bien donc là je
pense que déjà les blancs sont les bulls
ont perdu à mon sens déjà on va voir
dans l'espace donc là un homme joue le
coup mais maintenant je joue le coup que
tu proposes à la retraite sauf que
maintenant ce coup perd de manière
forcée ce coup perdu la force et donc je
la préférais peut-être dame b 3 mesdames
b3 aussi illustre un peu les difficultés
avec l idée alors l'idée l'idée ce
serait de faire pression sur ce cavalier
alors l'idée oui c'est aussi de chasse à
ce fou là de poires peut-être joué fou
b52 faut bien qu'ils pourraient attaquer
la dame de prendre ce câble et qui
protège le pion c5 voilà en essayant de
faire une pression que moi c'est bien
pour l omble en a l'air perdu il faut
absolument que l'inde récupère ce pion
ses pions et donc il doit exercer une
pression mais bon en fait on n'a pas
vraiment de conseils de grands
conseillers donné je pense que les
blancs ils sont très mal là donc on voit
le couple d'amis les cinq pour les
blancs et maintenant la kasparov répond
un super cool qui gagne c'est ça - la
qualité je pense alors un cookie alors
effectivement un super coup un super
coup alors je vous ai trouvé que ce
qu'ils gagnent ou effectivement si un
coût puisque le four vient il filme une
suppression par l'annoncé faite sur la
blanche et fait pression sur lequel
veille à 4 qui est mal placé il cueille
la 4ème place et si la dame s'en va si
la dame s'en va le cavalier est perdu le
cavalier perdu donc effectivement donc
forcé changé d'âme parce que la dame
d'armes étant effectivement la dame des
landes et attaquer la menace des noirs
ces dames programme et après il faut
prendre un peu fou prend foule énorme a
mis en pièces donc voilà il faut
absolument énergie là il y avait aussi
mais là et donc il a joué d'un processus
donc d'un premier assist qui al air
forcé notez qu'il aurait pu jouer
qu'avait laissé 3 mais à ce moment là je
prends ces trois simplement
alors non on va regarder ça josé tu
proposes est aussi le coup cavalière c3
pour essayer de revenir et c'est on sait
jamais bien même le terminer
la fameuse menace protège la dame voilà
une fois mais mais on prend simplement
g7 peut prendre ce cavalier ou même le
cavalier du cavalier seul encore plus
fort parce que on menace cavale et prend
1,2
oui sa part avec échec voilà donc sa
série qu'est la ferte non strophes and
on peut pas ne peut même pu rapatrier
ses pièces vers le centre donc là on est
quand même obligé de prendre la dame de
grâce à l'offre et la garry kasparov
prend évidemment la dame d'un an avec le
fou et il ya toujours ce cavalier qui
est en l'air mais ce qu avait lui-même
est perdu est quoi disons il est pas
perdu mais maintenant il quel lycée
alors imaginons la défense pour les
blancs la socialite attaqué alors si les
blancs jouent ou par exemple b2 et b3
c'est le fou g7 qui se qui s'allument
ici et qui peut prendre la tour et qui
couronnent finalement son succès voilà
et on sait très bien qu'une tour est
beaucoup plus forte comme fou voilà et
que donc là et sparrow forêt un avantage
clair et net donc deuxième solution il
faut rapatrier le cavalier puisqu'il ya
pas d'autres pièces qui peuvent défendre
le terme eric que le pion donc il faudra
pas très lecavalier est là
kasparov pour reprendre car il y avait
le fou et ensuite reprendre le pion ils
contrôlent ils contrôlent deux fois
cette occasion qu'ils gagnent au moins
un pion gagne au moins un pion est pas
prêt il va falloir défendre le foie de
aussi oui et donc il va gagner trois
pions va gagner les élections des six
aussi avec donc regagné beaucoup de
pions catastrophe une catastrophe
faisant donc reste la seule solution à
roanne en solutions qui perd alors c'est
un peu
il choisit de prendre le cavalier de
quatre heures voilà obligé un kasparov à
faire une série des changes
voilà une seule chose qui lui est
bénéfique alors la question est ce que
kasparov par exemple pourrait reprendre
tout simplement le club allemand je
pense que le coup qu'il va faire gagner
la partie donc à mon avis on s'y prend
le cavalier la dengue peut revenir sur
la casse et 5 c'est que l'idée de cas
david nolande c'est de supprimer le
défenseur
voilà et maintenant j'espère va les
blancs pourraient prendre à casser 5
protégé par le fou voilà donc cavalli
prend et après le cavaly prendre des
noirs reprendre ici et voilà les noir et
blanc sont ok ouais les plans truqués
mais bon mais l'agacement fabiola est
sûre il ne fut plus grands pas le fou
mais il prend le cavalier donc la
seconde à sa demande dans une position
voilà donc là c'est c'est maintenant il
attaque de pièces il est avec le fou en
asie voilà c'est là l'idée de 2k sports
c'est que maintenant le fouillent
toujours attaquer en avion et
l'attaquent la tour et la tôle d'attaqué
donc ils ont à charge et une pièce pour
l'instant mais quoi pas enfin leur
avantage ils attaquent une paix directes
il est donc meilleur calcul devant la
championne du monde
disons moi je pense que non d'être
perdus ou était moins bien et après dame
b 5 fu 17 réfute parce que lecavalier a
capté tellement mal placé qu'il ait
perdu donc ce coup à la bande des
profits de quoi la bande des très très
douteux un conseil de josé de sousa ce
soir je la veux dire le borgne vraiment
un produit il l'a dit en début
d'émission
il réitère pendant la partie livrée que
le joueur qui a joué à rien on a perdu
voilà celui d'alger somme qu'avait il à
1,6 aussi oui oui et bien pas on viendra
me dans les très très précises et ils
m'ont il veut jouer ces cinq il signe
des très saine il se développe et il
joue ses cinq ans
c'est un principe général toujours là
aux échecs mais les exceptions
distinction exactement c'est vrai grand
mère française ou portugaises
il ya des exceptions exactement mais bon
voilà donc là on ne choisit de b2dix
récurent de récupérer un maximum de
matériel dont qui prend il prend le pion
bessette et la beauté que noter que si
on vient un petit peu en arrière juste
pour que s'il joue à b3 et bien issue
s'il joue et b3 pour justement enlever
la taxe oui le tour des deux baies 3 il
ya l'autre tour quitte à tequila le fou
ici en j'essaie de prendre l'a déjà
signalé leur change rien ça ne change en
rien la position donc toujours une hyper
toujours une qualité donc un homme prend
le pion maintenant kasparov reprend la
tour il ya deux solutions pour les
blancs soit prendre le fou là soit
prendre le cavalier bon moines à en vue
de la taxe sur des six par les cavaliers
bon il préfère prendre le fou donc le
carrier pas non voilà on prend le
cavalier voilà kasparov a tout vu
maintenant il prend lui-même le cavalier
adverse et maintenant maintenant 1 an 2
reprend voilà on a la foi commune alors
maintenant on le fait de combinaisons au
21e coup de blanc et quand même cette
position est encore intéressante parce
que son corps intéressante parce
allemande à halle et la paire de fou et
on sait que la paire de pousser très
fort le pion c5 est faible en plus il a
toujours son il a toujours gardé aussi
cinq attaques est tout simplement il a
toujours son pion des six en option vous
le prendre son pion passé on note
maintenant que la case devant le pion
est faible c'est à dire que
ben kasparov lui posent à notre pardon
possède le fou blanc et donc il a joué
en appel la paire de football voilà un
petit avantage oui un petit avantage
évident elle tour c'est moins bien mais
oui mais ça permet de lutter ça permet
de fabriquer et en plus il peut pousser
depuis un an 17 et le défendre par par
son fils peut pas remplacer le fou en c6
imaginé un plan pour un nombre
d'annoncés autour des 1 17
il a pris un coup ces six les mêmes
possibilités serait dans une position
très passive et donc il faut faire très
attention mais on va voir la classe de
kasparov dont castrés uniquement voilà
qu'ils ne signeraient réalisation
technique il a dû être parfaite
à mon sens en fait oui disent donc là on
le place par off reprend le pion aux
attaquants la tour aux douanes en voilà
un an que choisit le jouer le coup
autour des uns et la casse par judy coup
c'est là moi je pense que c'est un autre
super coup un super coup merci berck où
il joue le coup on va le voir tout de
suite le flou des coeurs en d4
alors d'autres rendant le pion rendant
le pion et changeant la paire de fou
mais ils échangent la paire de fudan sur
les pas de faussaires que maintenant il
va lutter avec une tournette disons
control fois là et encore comment il va
s'en sortir
et bien voilà il va donc y avait une
raison technique à mon avis parfaite
donc iront le pur on sentait souvent le
meilleur souvent le meilleur alors à
nantes obligé de rester attachés aux
anciennes on ne prend pas ces kasparov
qui menace est là il ya deux grandes
options des six et en plus la pièce deux
pièces étant des cas traités ils
s'entraîneront bien place et voit la
super prime placé le pinot noir des plus
le pion des noirs en c5 aurait pu
lui-même devenir dans la rue donc alors
choisi de prendre le fouille de rituels
pions donc un an de production et
maintenant la tour et prend on peut
récupérer que alors au final
kasparov aïn tour contre un fou pour
l'instant les options pour l'instant
voilà pour l'instant on en est encore en
plomb mais on va voir mais qu'est ce
qu'on va vraiment encore vu plus loin et
là il joue encore un très bon coup il
joue le coutour l'a7 bloc le pion c'est
à dire que justement le plan de blanc
était de jouer des six des sept et dix
mètres au faible et de risque à vélo
l'âme il se retrouve faible parce que la
case devant pion est faible alors on
peut noter alors c'est là où c'est très
joli parce que là non pour y jouer le
coup voilà fou un c6 et kasparov vous
serez obligé donc par exemple de revenir
en des huit ils pousseraient il
pousserait le pied en mai
mais il ya en plus alors je te laisse
donner là il ya encore un petit piège
c'était des policiers à lanzhou le
couffo c6 kasparov joute est interné
dans le coup pour en suite voilà
sacrifiant lourd
comment le choix je dirais ça quoi sur
la facture sapri fia l'a toujours et si
la nôtre à la tour et dans ce cas là la
tour viendrait en c1 avec un matt du
couvoir puisque les blancs sont coincés
ici dans leur fameux couloir de la mort
un feu toujours heureux je dois préciser
que dans une de nos partis ceux de
blitta vent avant le match je le garde
pour s'entraîner tu m'appeler c'est un
maître du couloir est érigée plus facile
des couloirs donc c'est vrai que c'est
un match et plaisance en place et on
peut mettre en fait dans ses filets
c'était plaisant il ya donc on peut
aller en service donc s'ils veulent ici
au g4 c'est un élève ne vous pouvez à
l'oeuf ou pourrait venir saccager 4 mais
tout simplement les mariages coup f7 un
f5 bloquant le slogan le fou est obligé
de partir et après la 2e tour viendra
taquet le pion il qui seraient perdus
donc là on en dise et trouver une
réfutation
non ils jouent le coup h 4 logique h4
exactement qui menace qui menace le coup
maintenant pousser 6 puisque le plateau
venait en civil qui aurait pu le mag du
couloir exactement donc ça obligerait la
tour à bouger et de jouer le coup de 17
qui bloquerait les noirs la catastrophe
a tout vu donc ils attaquent ils jouent
maintenant tout de suite l'attak du pion
si les blancs alors il ay là il a
affaibli le pion et maintenant ils
attaquent donc là on va sur ses blanc et
le blanc ne peuvent plus défendre le
purell des dents
alors l'homme choisi la contre attaque
maintenant au coût 26 des blancs tour à
4 046 vide noir prennent les blancs
prennent le pion à 7 et il peut encore
lutter et peuvent encore y t mais là
quel sport enfin encore faire un
brillant coup ils ont un coût de
techniques simples et a tout vu tomber
vite il joue le coutour en b vite c'est
tout simplement le plan des six ici il
va être attaqué par exemple si les
blancs jouent le coup pouce et 6 pour
attaquer la tôle à tour prendre
attaquant le fond et ensuite on va
protéger le pion à ses règlements et
maintenant si par contre
kasparov pardon hollande joue kelkoo
quelque peu joue il faut absolument
protéger ce pion alors maintenant langue
hindi ou fait de kasparov
c'est de prendre le pion des six avec la
tourbe évite donc son lycée de jouer
tour b6 et tours b 6 prend dès 6 h d'ang
lee j'essaie de prendre le pion à ne pas
perdre le pion à ses voilà c'est fait
oui de prendre
finalement la tour la tourbe et 8 le
prendre donc si on joue tous racistes
par exemple alors à tour s'il a tout
revient sur l'a46 protégeant le pion
dans ce classement n'a plus qu'a joué le
coup tourbes et 8b this voilà attaque la
tour attaqué à tenir on attaque le pion
et si la tour prends j'en prends tu
comprends et le pion été perdus et la
finalité la finale facilement gagné
alors kasparov quand on a vu les gars
spf a réussi avec une bonne technique
qui a transmis dans deux finales avec
alors que l'autre avait deux à la paire
de fou maintenant sans la paire de fou
oui ces films plus d'espoir l'espoir est
alors deuxième coup pour les pour les
blancs mais c'est le jouet le tout
simplement contours des quatre revenir
mais tout simplement le coup le coup de
8 ans b6 attaque pions là exactement et
donc c c est l idée de kasparov
parce qu'il a alors à jouer en dehors ce
que je vais d'ailleurs je viens du coup
tomber vite parce que s'activent les
pièces et kasparov
il aime ça en fait sa force sister la
tour était en début c'était un peu
passive et hop et tourbe est vite tombée
si c'est elle devient très exact mais il
a joué un petit peu la tour d'abord en
18 pour bloquer un petit pelé blanc a su
de la mettre en évidence et des coups
très simple mais qui montre quand même
ce talent de l'expérience et la nand
coût d'un land lavandou voilà ce qu'il
ya de plus sérieux mais il a dû serrer
la main de son adversaire
c'est ce qui va être la bonne puisque
qu'à soi on va récupérer ses pions et la
finale est techniquement gagner pour
kasparov sans trop de difficultés la
tour un coup plus fortes comme bon il va
quand même un peu souffrir mais bon
c'est alors c'est pas évident c'est vrai
pour un amateur peut-être de se rendre
voilà les joueurs menottes mais à ce
niveau là vraiment l'avantagé vraiment
trop fort et la lutte danon qui conforte
l'image de séance il va échanger une
tour pied privat y tv sony va sûrement
menacé de prendre le pion à deux là en
plus c'est ce qui peut faire si fixé le
pion à deux c'est à dire avancer son
pion jusqu'en à 3 par exemple à 5
accaparé trop rares fixant le pion après
il va ramener le roi est souvent le
thème le plus classique dans ses
positions la c2 c'est au fait de
sacrifier la tour contre le fu obligeant
les blancs à prendre du plomb en voilà
et pousser ensuite ou alors ou alors par
exemple le roi blanc lui doit rester ce
sont les droits pour défendre les pions
des droits donc le roi noir va vers le
centre
puis après vers le centre mais vers
l'est la dame puis après les noirs
sacrifie la tour entre le fou et gagne
facilement la finale de roi c'est le
plus généralement le plus simple et si
vous regardez un petit peu si vous avez
une
de petites bases de données vous
regarder facilement et vous verrez que
c'est souvent la technique la plus
longtemps on peut on peut inviter les
joueurs que ça intéresse les gens qui
s'intéressent à ici de jouer cette
partie contre l'ordinateur sinon
ordinateur voilà essayer de la gagner
avec les noirs oui mais kasparov qu'ils
n'auront aucun mal même contrôler un
ordinateur cette finale est
techniquement plus c'est bon là ça
existe en effet facilement le ca lustres
le style décasport a fait très bien
préparés grosse expérience a fait des
dizaines d'années qui jouent cette
position-là jeu entre karpov
alors moi j'ai envie de dire josé là on
a donc francfort
kasparov gagne clairement devant là il
vient de battre à nantes avec les noirs
en plus est ce que le match d'octobre du
coup nous n'est pas dévaluée moi je
pense pas c'est à dire que je ne pense
pas parce que la annonce est rentré dans
le jeu de kasparov
donc il a joué une ouverture connaissait
moins bien qu'à ce père en fils mais
s'il joue des positions stratégiques
on vous des positions un petit peu fermé
ou kasparov peut s'énerver parce que
kasparov des fois souvent à tendance un
peu à s'énerver et non pas trois temps
il n'aime pas trop attendre donc si
quelqu'un avant d'arriver à lui faire
une petite manoeuvre et c est mon avis
un nombre de vos vins sera bien préparé
pour ce pour ce pour ceux qui souhaitent
travailler un petit peu voilà et yves
agid jeu contre auxerre je suis des
conseils en tout cas des choses les
ouvertures ou kasparov a une grosse
expérience et si on a la chance ou
malchance de casser non mais là pour
anand dans le coup mais je pense qu'il
le monde le sait très bien et fait la
chanson mahler ayant cédé plus courants
comment on voit la chose
donc voilà dernière une formation on va
terminer donc très belles parties de
kasparov victoire contre un an
on va peut-être terminée maintenant
cette émission puisqu'il nous reste
encore de 30 minutes avec une
information quand même intéressante
puisque c'est au championnat du monde
et là c'est simple karpov qui avait un
petit peu tergiversé ce que je vais
jouer ce que je vais pas jouer il
voulait pas trop jouer il est donc
champion du monde encore en titre karpov
de la fédération internationale et
finalement il annonce sa participation à
las vegas oui est ce qu'il n'est pas un
peu obligé disons quand même bon i
bon c'est vrai qu'il est champion du
monde il n'a pas repris ces derniers
mois et on pourrait se dire bon ben
voila j'ai été champion du monde
maintenant je me sors de la scène mais
karpov est un joueur il aime jouer et à
mon avis il veut encore prouvé au monde
qu'il est le l'un des meilleurs joueurs
du monde
voilà peut-être ans bien qu'il ait envie
de se jeter dans l'arène et en fait je
pense que c'est c'est un joueur c'est à
dire c'est comme les gens qui vont au
casino n'en faut pas que j'aie faut pas
que j'y aille et puis finalement et
allons-y là peut qu'asseoir of lui ne
fout pas de mac est cependant il peut se
permettre ces meilleurs joueurs du monde
il peut se remettre de faire un peu ce
qu'il veut
donc là il joue pas las vegas mais je
pressens championnat du monde sur le
perso en fait oui en tout cas c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour nom des échecs que
le champion du monde en titre défendre
son petit travail et grâce ça santana
ça donne une crédibilité à ce chat par
le monde on aura tous les meilleurs
joueurs du monde sauf kasparov et un an
ce qui est dommage un peu mais c'est
vrai que ce qui est dommage mais bon ils
ont choisi ils ont choisi de ne pas le
jouer
on verra alors le match quel sport
d'endurance moi aussi est intéressant
moi ce que j'aimerais voir ça match
kasparov cramique parce que mais bon moi
je préférerais un match de sport sur wii
mais je pense qu'il aura pas de match
mais là parce que oui parce que je suis
pas le même style uca sport en fils aime
les positions très tactique 13ème les
positions très tendue et la casse
parfait plus fort je pense que si amanda
rival à le tirer dans son terrain dans
des positions stratégiques de manoeuvre
il peut faire quelque chose
enfin rappelez quand même classement
fait déjà rencontré non mais il a déjà
fait de france vers new york en 95 et il
a battu et il a mené d'un point
d'ailleurs dominé d'un poil
ils menaient hamon
le match mais c'est du moment il a mené
en fait qu'à semences énervé il a
rétabli à rétablir les choses assez
clairement
voilà donc de notre émission se termine
on arrivait à faire merci dit de quel
honneur d'avoir été invités puis donc je
pense qu'il y aura d'autres occasions
que tu reviennes sur les gones est en
tout cas ça sera avec grand plaisir
ou alors bonsoir et puis bon anoeta tôt
voilà donc on saura à nos amis portugais
de la part de josé de sousa et à tous
mes amis français champion des pays
engagent junior 1992
voilà il fait jour voilà mais je vous
dit bonsoir donc as une prochaine pour
une nouvelle émission de diagonale